The most commonly used symmetric
encryption algorithms are the so
called block ciphers.
A block cipher takes as input
a plaintext in fixed sized blocks, and
it produces a block of ciphertext of
equal size, for each plain text block.
To process a longer plain text, we can
first break the plain text into a series
of fixed size blocks, and then,
apply block ciphers to each block.
The most important symmetric algorithms,
all of which are block ciphers, are the
data encryption standard, or DES, and
the advanced encryption standard or AES.
We will present more technical details
of these algorithms in a later lecture.
For now, we note that these two
different algorithms have different
block sizes and key length.
We call that, a longer key length
means that there are more keys.
As a result, a brute force attack has
to do more work to try all the keys.
This table shows how
much time is required for
brute force attack for
various key lengths.
As we can see in the table,
DES user key length of 56.
And a number of possible keys,
is 2 to the 56th.
If a single personal computer is
used to try all the possible keys,
it takes about a year.
If multiple PCs, for example, tens of
thousands of PCs, work in parallel,
then the time is drastically shortened.
And today's super computers should be
able to try all the possible keys,
using DES, in an hour.
Key sizes of 128 bits or greater
are effectively unbreakable using,
simply, brute force methods.
For example, even with a super computer,
it would take 10 to 17 years,
to try all the possible keys using AES.